this dollar bill has a disease it might
seem healthy but if you look real close
you'll see a virus that is slowly but
surely eating away its purchasing power
every day this particular virus is named
inflation every dollar in your bank
account is infected with it if you got
our taking on high school economics
class you've probably already heard the
term but most of us only know that it's
the reason one day we'll tell our
grandkids back in my day MacBook Pros
only cost one Bitcoin but inflation
isn't just some benign force it's why
getting a raise is so important
wipe the cost of education is spiraling
out of control and in extreme examples
it's affecting millions of people's
ability to put food on the table and
it's something you need to learn how to
live alongside without letting it
sideline your financial goals
[Music]
now inflation wouldn't be such a big
deal if everything inflated at the exact
same rate
who cares if housing prices skyrocketed
if your salary instantly compensated to
match the problem arises because
different things inflate at different
rates and sometimes for completely
different reasons there are two main
types the first is cost push inflation
this is when companies are forced to
raise prices because the cost of the
materials to make the thing or provide
the service has gone up for example did
you happen to notice how vanilla ice
cream is getting more expensive
Madagascar the world's largest supplier
has been consistently hit with terrible
storms that have been destroying the
delicate crop so if the company's
relying on vanilla want to keep their
profit margins the same they will have
to consider pushing that increased cost
unto their customers in the form of a
higher price which they can get away
with to a certain point assuming the
economy is healthy enough for it to not
affect demand too dramatically then
there's a demand pull inflation take our
hometown Austin it's a rapidly growing
city but the supply of housing hasn't
been able to match the demand meaning
landlords and people selling their homes
are in the position to ask higher prices
than they did the year before
while both of these examples aren't
super fun on our wallet inflation is in
many scenarios related to growth when an
economy is growing the overall demand
for goods goes on conversely when the
economy isn't doing well inflation tends
to decrease because there's not enough
demand to support a price increase but
like a virus if inflation is allowed to
run rampant really really bad things can
happen
take Venezuela corruption combined with
economic mismanagement and an
authoritarian government has led to a
humanitarian crisis of epic proportions
the hyperinflation is so bad that the
government refuses to share any official
numbers so Bloomberg created the Cafe
con Leche index measuring the price of a
cup of coffee in eastern Caracas in
March of 2018
cup of coffee cost 1.2 bolivars and just
one year later that same cup cost 2,800
bolivars it's no wonder that nearly a
third of the population has left the
country so whose job is it to make sure
that doesn't happen here in the US it's
the Federal Reserve the Fed is the bank
of banks and its job is to essentially
walk the tightrope between encouraging
the economy to grow aka allowing prices
to rise but at the same time keeping
inflation from gaining too much ground
and taking away the purchasing power of
its citizens the Fed tries to fight
inflation in three different ways
setting the interest rate that banks
borrow money from them adjusting how
much cash banks are required to have on
hand and deciding how much new money can
be printed these methods control how
much money's floating around the economy
the more money floating around the more
liberal banks feel about lending it out
so interest rates go down which means
it's easier for people like you and me
to get a mortgage credit card a student
or small business loan and the economy
grows but if it grows too fast prices
will go up faster than wages can keep
pace and your savings are suddenly worth
a lot less that money you set aside for
a Hawaiian vacation will now only get
you as far as San Antonio there's no
question that regulating inflation on a
macroeconomic level is massively
complicated thankfully unless your
current Federal Reserve Chairman Jerome
Powell you don't have any control over
it
but on the micro economic level it's
your job to inoculate yourself and guess
what only one vaccine out there
investing most people know they should
invest but why why can't you simply save
your way into wealth I think it's time
to run the numbers
this is Trisha she feels sort of scared
of the stock market and travels a lot so
she doesn't feel like owning real estate
for the foreseeable future what if she
wanted to try and save money into a
checking account to get her to her
personal retirement goal of eight
hundred and fifty thousand dollars if
inflation didn't exist it would be
pretty simple algebra if she started
saving at thirty and wanted to retire at
65 that would require her to save two
thousand twenty three dollars per month
in order to hit her nesting goal a
challenging number to hit even for
higher earners but the reality with
inflation is way worse
the feds goal is to keep inflation at
around the 2% per year so let's say that
actually happens that means in order to
keep the same purchasing power of eight
hundred and fifty thousand dollars in
the future
her new goal will have to be adjusted to
around 1.7 million dollars that would
require her to set aside double the
money or the equivalent of four thousand
forty seven dollars per month
yikes but a trisha decided to educate
herself a bit and move past her
investing fears she could harness the
same forces that created the inflation
in the first place to her benefit if she
decided to invest her way to retirement
through some stock based mutual funds
with an average return of 8 percent per
year
she could still hit that 1.6 million
dollar goal by only saving 822 dollars a
month okay well that's not chump change
that sounds way more realistic than 4
grand a month it's also important for
Trisha to keep a close eye on her income
if it doesn't increase to keep pace with
inflation she's essentially making less
money every year even if her salary
stays the same so instead of seeing
inflation as an evil virus let's think
of it like another invisible powerful
force the wind you can choose to work
against it or hoist a sail and let the
forces at play work on your behalf and
that's our two cents thanks to our
patrons for keeping two cents
financially healthy click the link in
the description if you would like to
support us on patreon
have you noticed the effect of inflation
in your life tell us about it in the
comments
[Music]